there is a reason why Jamal Murray was
able to look at that really bad floor
burn that he got during game three and
just shake it off turns out he went
through pain tolerance drills when he
was younger to prepare him for moments
like this his dad would make him hold a
squat while balancing scorching hot Cups
of Tea on his thighs he said he would
stay like that for a while and sometimes
without a clock timing him his dad would
also have him pick up leaves outside
when it was cold out so that if Jamal
was ever in a cold gym his hands would
be ready he said these things really
helped him build his pain threshold the
man is intense